[Music]
welcome to
the great pantry bake off next to me is
our one and only contestant catherine
who you may wonder let me start over
i'm sorry not so hi by the way the
reason chris is talking in a terrible
british accent is because i'm obsessed
with the great british bake off
we're currently on quarantine right now
so we are staying home and i thought
it'd be really fun to have our own like
great british bake off and i forced
chris to be the host i love doing it
it's fantastic
i have selected four items from our
pantry that you're going to have to use
in a dessert recipe of your choosing
they are coffee creamer box of pudding
jar of raspberry jam
and a can of peaches so i just have to
use these but i can use anything else in
the pantry please yes okay thank you yes
let's just say i'm putting you
to the test
okay i've thought about it a lot and
when i say a lot i mean like five
minutes
i'm gonna be making a peach pudding
raspberry tart with raspberry
raspberry with raspberry meringues on
top i thought an easy shortbread cookie
crust would be super delicious with the
pudding so first
we'll add one cup of flour a quarter cup
of sugar
and a quarter teaspoon salt mix those
together and then i've melted a stick of
butter so you'll just add that to your
bowl and then mix it all together
so this is going to be delicious
take a tart pan with a removable bottom
take our dough
and place it right there i'm just going
to take my hands which i've washed
and press
in the dough
[Music]
okay oh i'm hot in here great the dough
has been spread out on the tart pan i'm
gonna throw this in the oven at 350
degrees fahrenheit for about 20 minutes
just until it has like a nice golden
color and then we'll let it cool we can
do this
okay while that is baking i'm gonna prep
the peaches first
open the can if you can oh
and i can wow
strain the peaches try to get off as
much
juice
as you can on there save this juice to
use in our filling so just set that
aside for right now in a larger bowl
place your peaches and you're just gonna
mash away
it's a great way to get out you know
some stress
i'm sure i'm sure everyone's a little
bit stressed so
this is a good way to
work out those feelings
and just
mash it up as best you can until it's in
little clumps
we're going to set this aside
and i have
so i have our tart
this has cooled to the touch and we have
that nice golden brown not too dark next
step i've measured out about a half a
cup of this jam so just spread that out
along the bottom nice and even
[Music]
perfect i'm gonna go put this in the
freezer for about 10 minutes just so it
can kind of solidify on the bottom i've
got a lot of food in the freezer right
now
hopefully i can make room for this wish
me luck
why do i always want to creep out for
the rest of the filling i'm going to be
making kind of a peaches and cream
pudding first thing i'm going to take is
one cup of milk
instant vanilla pudding
and we're going to do a quarter cup of
this coffee creamer
and i'm gonna add a quarter cup of that
reserved peaches liquid
whisk that up
i've actually never made instant pudding
so i'm excited to see how it's gonna
turn out now i'm gonna add in our peach
puree
and we'll just fold that into
the pudding
so this is super
liquidy which i don't think is right is
this not
nope nope because this is not instant
pudding and you gotta do this on the
stove so it thickens up let's
let's go to the stovetop
magic i've been home way too long i'm
gonna put this guy in a medium saucepan
i'm gonna heat this over medium-high
heat until it comes to a boil that will
make it pudding oh man i'm waiting for
this pudding to boil it's just in the
pudding is at a boil i'm gonna stir him
up
remove him from the heat and we're gonna
let that cool and as the box says it'll
thicken
as it cools
okay our pudding has cooled our
raspberry jam has set so i am just gonna
take this pudding
and put it across the top to take a
knife to make sure it's nice and smooth
after that i'm going to cover with
plastic wrap
right on top of it actually you're just
going to let that lay
flat on top place this in the freezer
for about two hours it's five o'clock so
i do not have a lot of time till sundown
so for my final element i'm going to be
making raspberry meringue cookies
meringue is one of those kind of tricky
things a lot of things can go wrong with
it even though there's very few
ingredients so tip one when it comes to
making meringues is you want to have a
clean bowl with no water so make sure
it's super dry first add two egg whites
you also want to be sure there's no egg
yolks in your egg whites next i'm going
to use a little bit of cream of tartar
this is going to help stabilize my eggs
and make it a little bit more foolproof
add a quarter teaspoon of the cream of
tartar then on a low speed we're going
to whip these eggs up until they become
foamy
okay now that that's nice and foamy i'm
gonna whip this at a high speed until we
get soft peaks
gradually mix in a half a cup of
granulated sugar start at a low speed
and just do about a couple tablespoons
at a time
as this goes i'm going to gradually
bring the speed up
you really don't want to rush this part
i have and it does not work out well
keep mixing this at a high speed until
it gets really thick and form stiff
peaks basically i've taken the jam i've
put it through a strainer to get out the
seeds and then we're going to
incorporate that a little bit into our
meringue
beautiful
now that we're done adding the jam i'm
going to take a piping bag with a piping
tip take some of the leftover jam the
remaining
i'm just going to line the sides of our
piping bag with it
then take your meringue and you're going
to put it in to the piping bag we don't
want to overfill it so that looks good
and then you'll squeeze that to the end
so i have a baking sheet with a silt pad
on it you can do parchment paper just
something nonstick
okay let's uh let's give this a try
we're done with these guys they
definitely kind of have an ombre effect
some have a lot of jam and then it gets
a lot lighter i think these look pretty
cute i'm gonna put them in the oven at
200 degrees fahrenheit and bake them for
about an hour or until they're easy to
kind of pick up off the baking pan okay
our meringues are out of the oven and
i've let them cool
i also found in the back of the freezer
some raspberries i had frozen a while
ago so i'm going to use those too i'm
just going to place them kind of like an
egg crescent shape around the top of the
tart
[Music]
a nifty trick to get your tart out of
your tart pan you can take a can
place it on your table and you take your
tart very carefully and you set it down
and then voila i like how it turned out
i have no idea how it tastes because
again i've never made this before we're
gonna let chris be the guinea pig here
and taste it press okay you can open
your eyes
oh
this looks beautiful
so it's a raspberry peach pudding tart
with a shortbread crust gorgeous and
raspberry meringue swirl cookies on the
top i'm really excited to taste it it
looks great these look great how did you
get these to look like this i piped them
okay hard work
let's see how it cuts all right
oh wow okay not as clean layers
this looks really great i'm actually
super excited to dive into this why are
you going for a super hungry i'm scared
this here
whoa whoa very aggressive very
aggressive honestly ah oh my god there
got it oh my golly miss paul okay now
i'm trying it
hmm
it's really really good with the rice
when you get a bite with a fresh
raspberry oh yeah okay this is really
great based on this you are
[Music]
the winner of great pantry bacon
you are i'm the only one that's here
and of course
your prize great pantry baker
yay thank you
cookies cookies what are you talking
about
oh you're a maniac what am i just saying
goodbye these days cookies
cookies
[Music]
you